listen i'm not sure
maybe i shouldn't go jody
you've been begging me for weeks you're
not gonna back up now
i don't know anybody there they might
all hate me and
stress is awful
let's just go just take a deep breath
there's no reason to pay me it's just a
birthday party
i'm sure everybody will like you you'll
have fun maybe meet some new friends
go on
oh don't forget your present
it's a book of poetry by poe it's 50
years old and very rare i'm sure she'll
like it
don't worry it's gonna be all right
i'll pick you up at five have fun
hey jody come in hi hey kirsten you
coming i gotta go
come in jody don't be shy hey jody right
come on we're in the living room some
girls from high school and least dorky
guys we could find
was it a present for me cool thanks
i'm off darling i'll look after your
friends and don't do anything all right
sure mom whatever you say
finally she gets the hint
hey everyone this is jody she's in unit
4 with my mom
unit 4 the paranormal department
what you do there ben spoons or speak to
dead people
stuff like that no party time
i'll get the beer guys do the shutters
girls do the candles and jody you can
take care of the music
let's get crazy
what kind of garbage is that slide over
we'll put on something from this century
something really popping
you're a genius daddy want one
[Music]
no thanks i i don't drink
you know you're missing girl after three
or four beers
you'll see the world in a whole new life
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
want some
no thanks
[Music]
beautiful body
i know what you're thinking you're
wondering why we're here
i'm thinking the same thing
i know you told me
i just wanted to see what it would be
like to
go out and have friends
this is not what i expected
[Music]
someone just crank up the air
conditioner i just caught a cold blast
so
[Music]
is
what's that
[Music]
is
[Music]
hi hi i'm matt jodie right
i've never seen you at school before you
don't take classes on base
i'm in a different program with my own
teacher
because i should remember fighting you
around before
so you work with kirsten's mother
yeah we worked in the same lab
she thought it would be a good idea for
me to come and spend time with people my
age so
uh here i am i used to live in
london before i moved here two years ago
and you
where did you live before
new york
man i love new york it's awesome i went
there once it blew me away
do you have any hobbies anything you do
for like fun
i surf any chance i get and i play in a
band with a bunch of friends
[Music]
and you what are you into
it's gonna sound really boring
i like to read and
i like sports
i mean i i can't i can't leave the base
so it
sort of limits things can i
can i ask you something
why are you in unifor
i'd rather not talk about it
[Music]
are you up for it
[Music]
sure
tonight i will surrender
[Music]
you know i'm sure you hear this all the
time but
you're really pretty you know
[Music]
do you say that to all the girls you
mean
you're not like other girls i mean
there's something special about
you
[Music]
i think you're pretty special too
[Music]
savior
[Music]
i can't keep up with you
i don't know what to do
[Music]
guys guys why doesn't jody give us a
demonstration of her
super mega powers no great idea
i'd pay to see that oh forget it it's
just a little bowl
yeah come on jody show us what you can
do okay jody
you up for demonstration
no no i i don't i don't have anything
to show i told you so guys it's all
[ __ ]
right okay guys it's time to eat that
delicious cake and most important to
open my birthday gifts
actually the k can wait i'm opening my
gifts first
love gen xxx oh that's nice babe
i bet it's knee socks a thong
just exactly what i needed now you can
stop stealing your moms and improve your
chances of finding a decent boyfriend
my future lover wants to thank you for
making his life more
interesting
what is that an old book
it smells funky it's a really rare
collection uh poems by edgar allan poe
hey girl and who what did you steal this
from your grandpa's library
no no and it's really rare yeah
just like your dress
but seriously is this a joke i can't
believe you came all the way to my
birthday party just to give me this old
crap
and she thinks she's so clever but she's
just a little labra
a freaky little lab rat yeah
she's been following me around like a
puppy all evening begging for it
oh and she's a [ __ ] too i never wanted
to invite her my mom made me
yeah she's a [ __ ] a starting witch
we should like do something to her
what do you do with witches you burn
them
please please let me out the first
moment i said
please let me out
please someone say cake please i want to
get out
please i want to get out i'm back
[Music]
get me out of here please
know
[Music]
so
[Music]
you